je vous propose une petite balade ça
vous dit alors on y va
je vous propose une balade sur un marché
aux puces il ya une dizaine d'années je
me baladais sur le marché aux puces de
saint-ouen au nord de paris et sur la
fin de ma balade je m'aperçois que les
étalons baisser le niveau et sont au sol
j'en regarde de plus près voir ce qui
est vendu et je vois une petite boîte en
mauvais état un livre paroles de prévert
très bon des petits ciseaux et surtout
un talon de chaussure qui peut bien
acheter ou vendre un talon de chaussure
alors ce que vous voyez là est un étal
de biffins les biffins sont des
personnes qui récupèrent dans nos
poubelles ce que nous jetons pour
ensuite le revendre sur les trottoirs
dans l'espace public c'est leurs objets
sont étalés au sol sur un tissu ou une
bâche
c'est pour au plus vite en rabattre les
quatre coins et fuir fuir parce que
cette activité est aujourd'hui interdite
les biffins en cours avec la loi loppsi
2 une peine d'emprisonnement de six mois
et 3750 euros damende sont aujourd'hui
des milliers à vivre assure vivre de
cette activité aux portes de paris où
ils sont environ 3000 mais aussi dans
d'autres grandes villes comme marseille
toulouse lyon bordeaux et à l'étranger
aussi
moi je suis cadre dans le travail social
et en 2009 avec l'association qui
m'embauche des biffins la mairie de
paris et du xviiie arrondissement
nous allons mener un projet expérimental
pour que les biffins puisse vendre
légalement sur un espace dédié
mais l'histoire que je vais avant tout
vous raconter est une histoire de luttes
une histoire de compter
station l'histoire d'un travail social à
la marche face au paradoxe de notre
société
alors justement les paradoxes de notre
je me suis intéressé à l'histoire des
biffins et j'ai découvert que depuis le
xiiie siècle leurs relations avec
l'institution n'ont été que autorisation
répression autorisation répression et ça
en fonction des évolutions de la société
et de ses normes
par exemple ou 19e siècle après à paris
ils sont près de 22000 à récupérer des
chiffons des matières premières en tout
genre pour les revendre à l'industrie
là ils ont réelle utilité économique
reconnu la préfecture de paris va même
légaliser et réglementer l'activité en
délivrant à chaque biffins une médaille
pour marquer l'autorisation mais arrive
le courant islamiste et les grands
travaux haussmanniens et là les biffins
dérange on veut une ville propre bien
organisés et les biffins vont passer de
l'homme utiles à l'homme marginal ils
vont être alors expulsé aux portes de
paris où ils vont y construire des
baraques de fortune
mais continuer leurs activités et à
saint-ouen par exemple un groupe de
biffins va se constituer en chambre
syndicale
c'est simple ils veulent la
reconnaissance de la biffe l'eau
l'électricité
il leur faudra plusieurs dizaines
d'années de luttes de rapport de force
pour faire plier les pouvoirs publics
et c'est comme ça que va naître dans les
années 50 le célèbre marché aux puces de
saint-ouen
on va donc passer du bidonville à la
renommée internationale
mais comme l'histoire se répète depuis
les années 90 dans le prolongement des
puces de saint-ouen
là où j'ai vu le fameux talon de
chaussure des biffins réapparaissent
ne sont à ce moment là qu'une
quarantaine et leur nombre ne pose pas
de problème que ce soit pour les
riverains les commerçants et la police
tolèrent même le phénomène passé les
années 2000 la donne change
la crise économique le chômage pousse
près d'un millier de biffins à
s'installer à cet endroit
ils sont maintenant au pied des
habitations devant les commerces
alors là il n'est plus du tout question
de vieux métiers de recyclage ou
d'écologie mais de désordre public et de
transgression de la loi punit fermement
alors pour les plus jeunes et les plus
rapides il rabat les quatre coins de
leur tissu avec leurs objets se sauver
et pour les plus vieux et les plus lents
soit il abandonne tout derrière eux en
se sauvant laissant les trottoirs
jonchés d'objets en tout genre piétiner
soit c'est la saisie de leurs objets
avec leur destruction immédiate dans des
camions bennes alors vous vous
demanderez peut-être qui sont ces
indésirables ces hors la loi eh bien ce
sont des retraités des retraités qui ont
un revenu insuffisant pour finir le mois
ce sont des immigrés des chibanis venus
travailler en france est aujourd'hui à
la retraite chibani veut dire cheveux
blancs ce sont des hommes et des femmes
en pleine dégringolade sociale suite à
un divorce à la perte d'un emploi
et puis ce sont aussi des étudiants se
sont suffisait mieux parce que je vois
les photos et voilà c'est je les revois
et je suis extrêmement ému et ce sont
aussi ceux qui fuient leur pays
ces magnifiques photos sont de jérôme
pavlovsky
alors dans ce contexte totalement
explosive entre riverains biffins élus
un groupe décide de prendre les choses
en main les biffins eux mêmes en 2006 il
décide qu'ils n'ont plus à subir cette
répression
ils veulent leur reconnaissance de leur
activité de recyclage qui s'inscrit dans
une réelle économie puisque s'ils
vendent c'est bien que d'autres achètent
ils vont alors se constituer en
association et s'appelait et sauve qui
peut sauve qui peut c'est leur cri de
guerre quand ils ont à fuir ils vont
militer manifesté pendant trois années
il embarque avec eux des élus des
sympathisants des artistes et même
quelques riverains ensemble ils vont
débarquer lors de réunions publiques
ils vont interpeller les élus ils vont
solliciter pas mal de médias aussi et
ils vont même aller jusqu à camper sur
le parvis de l'hôtel de ville en
déballant symboliquement leurs objets et
à force de de lutte et ténacité
au bout de ces trois années finissent
par obtenir des pouvoirs publics qu'une
expérience soit tenté le projet
expérimental du carré des biffins selon
les termes créer un espace de vente
légale strictement limitées et délimité
assorti d'un accompagnement social
en d'autres termes créer un espace de
vente de 100 places
alors qu ils sont un millier est plutôt
réfractaire à l'idée d'être aidés sans
place un millier
alors vous vous demandez peut-être
pourquoi j'accepte de travailler sur ce
projet et bien tout d'abord je suis
touché par cette économie de la
débrouille parce que c'est un peu mon
histoire
j'avais une grand-mère qui recyclait
l'étain des capsules de bouteilles de
vin pour le revendre et grâce à cela
elle arrondissait ses fins de mois alors
je ne vais pas connue mais c'est ma mère
qui qui me la raconter et pour moi c'est
une belle légende belle légende
familiale dont je suis fier alors me
rapprocher des biffins c'était me
rapprocher de cette histoire là et puis
il ya aussi la lutte
je les trouve courageux admirable à
défier comme ça l'institution comme dit
saül alinsky les gens ne reçoivent pas
l'opportunité la liberté l'égalité où la
dignité comme on reçoit un cadeau ou un
acte de charité
il ne les reçoivent que par l'acte de
les prendre au prix de leurs propres
efforts et puis il ya aussi cette idée
d'arriver sur leur territoire pour une
fois ce n'est pas le nôtre ce sont eux
les experts de la biffe et du commerce
et nous travailleurs sociaux nous allons
devoir comprendre apprendre et inventer
un fonctionnement à partir de leurs
connaissances à eux
et puis je dois dire que cette histoire
de place hier de marché cadre du social
ça m'amuse un peu enfin ça ne va pas
m'amuser très longtemps les choses vont
s'avérer bien plus compliquée que prévu
et oui il était hors la loi ils sont
dans la loi et je m'aperçois qu'on ne
change pas aussi facilement un
fonctionnement qui jusque là était basée
sur la crainte la débrouillardise la
fuite de sauve qui peut alors non ils ne
sont pas restés sagement dans leur petit
emplacement comme de bons petits
commerçants de marchés en attendant le
client
pourquoi parce qu'il circule ils
circulent toute la journée ils sont à
gauche à droite font des affaires il
troque qui leur vendent ils y voilà il
n'arrête pas et puis surtout ils sont
irrégulier et imprévisible à cause de la
dureté du travail oui mais aussi de leur
âge parce qu'ils sont malades
les intempéries et puis surtout parce
qu'ils ne savent pas ce que les
poubelles vont donner alors avec eux
tous les samedis dimanches et lundis
pendant onze heures sur les trottoirs
nous avons appris les codes de la biffe
la culture les habitudes et ensemble
nous avons négocié un fonctionnement de
marchés et inscrit cette activité dans
un cadre
ces photos sont sous le pont donc du
périphérique
justement en parlant de cadres nous de
notre côté nous l'avons un petit peu
transgresser aussi le cadre nous avions
par exemple des critères de
domiciliation à faire respecter pour que
les biffins puisse être inscrit sur le
carré sauf que pour un bis fin ça n'a
pas de sens d'habiter ici ou là dans
leur travail sont nomades au quotidien
donc nous nous sommes dit le critère qui
comptera sera le critère d'ancienneté de
biff sur le territoire oui mais comment
le prouver
ils nous ont dit pas de problème vous
savez ce qu'ils nous ont ramenés des
liasses de pv des liasses de pb c'est
l'épaisseur qui faisaient l'ancienneté
alors le carré commence peu à peu à
prendre forme et autour l'insupportable
demeure 100 places ils sont un millier
pour ceux qui n'ont pas leur place sur
le précieux car et c'est la chasse la
répression le paradoxe total
quand on sait que ceux qui sont dedans
et dehors sont au final les mêmes alors
devant cette situation des plus
schizophrène nous allons rapidement
demandé la création d'autres espaces de
vente puisque la solution est là nous
sommes en train d'en faire la
démonstration
un marché de biffins ça peut s'organiser
sas réglemente même les pouvoirs publics
vont nous répondre non non ils ne
veulent pas généraliser cette activité
qu'ils considèrent informel est accordée
du coup les mêmes droits à tous les
biffins donc ils choisissent sa
répression
cette répression qui désorganise et qui
plongent ces précaires dans encore plus
de précarité alors tout en répondant à
cette commande un peu folle nous allons
de notre côté commencé à militer en
parallèle à côté des sauve qui peut
alors le travail tous sociale dans tout
ça vous me direz eh bien nous avons fait
face à une très grande précarité pour
beaucoup il s'est agit de répondre à des
besoins primaires se loger se nourrir se
laver et puis pour d'autres c'était
plutôt la méfiance
ils étaient réfractaires à l'idée d'être
aidé je repense à monsieur amar monsieur
amar avait le droit à sa retraite depuis
plus de cinq ans mais parce qu'un jour
il a été mal reçu par un travailleur
social
il a décidé de ne plus jamais demandé d'
aide à qui que ce soit et de s'en sortir
par lui même avec la biffe sans sa
retraite il nous aura fallu environ plus
d'un an plus d'un an avec lui son
trottoir à d'abord le considérer dans
son travail avant qu'il accepte de nous
faire confiance et qui nous permettent
et qui nous permettent de l'aider à voir
sa retraite
et puis il à ceux pour qui le car est un
espace de socialisation
monsieur 1000 euros par exemple on
l'appelle comme ça parce qu'il récupère
dans les poubelles des beaux quartiers
des mallette en cuir des sacs de la
fourrure et lorsqu'un client lui demande
le prix dit un prix boutique très élevé
alors évidemment il ne vend rien parce
que ce qui compte pour monsieur 1000
euros ce n'est pas de vendre c'est
d'être derrière son étal debout digne
comme un commerçant de luxe
ce monsieur a presque cent ans c'est un
chibani venus travailler en france
aujourd'hui il est à la retraite
sa famille est restée au pays il est
seul et sa vie à lui
elle est ici avec ses compagnons de
route
ses compagnons de beef alors aujourd'hui
le carré fonctionne toujours avec ses
hauts et ses bas
on peut dire qu'il a quand même trouvé
sa place sur son territoire les
riverains l'ont progressivement accepté
même si la situation est extrêmement
complexe autour et les sauve qui peut
quant à eux continuent leur combat
moi j'ai quitté cette incroyable
aventure qui m'a bouleversé où j ai fait
des rencontres humaines inoubliable mais
qui m'a aussi beaucoup puisé dans ses
paradoxes
alors j'ai décidé de prendre du recul
pour comprendre ce que j'avais fait ce
que nous avions fait ensemble et j'ai
décidé d'écrire cette histoire dans un
livre pour la transmettre au plus grand
nombre mais aussi pour la transmettre
aux travailleurs sociaux d'aujourd'hui
de demain et je crois et j'en suis sûr
surtout pour rendre hommage à ces
travailleurs courageux
les biffins
alors si je suis venu vous parler de
cette expérience
ici la saint brieuc de cette expérience
qui s'est déroulé à paris c'est parce
qu'en réalité elle questionne au delà de
ce territoire
elle questionne par exemple ce que doit
être l'espace public
aujourd'hui l'espace public est pensé
comme un espace vide
pourquoi au contraire ne pas le penser
comme un espace social négociable
capables par exemple d'accueillir les
biffins en bonne intelligence sociale et
collective parce qu'avant tout l'espace
public n'est pas un territoire
d'habitation mais d'actions et puis ce
projet question aussi c'est une nouvelle
forme de précarité de marginalité serge
moscovici psychosociologue dit le grand
tournant et le passage de la déviance à
la minorité active des hommes et des
femmes considérées comme des marginaux
des déviants créent aujourd'hui des
mouvements collectifs possèdent leurs
codes propres et cherche par eux mêmes à
répondre à leurs besoins
mais c'est comme ça que naît le
mouvement féministe écologiste les
syndicats ce que l'on appelle
aujourd'hui les cultures urbaines
mais au départ le graff le hip hop et ce
sont aussi les indignés les punks les
biffins et tant d'autres alors tout
l'enjeu aujourd'hui pour l'institution
pour le travail social c'est comment
négocier avec ces personnes comment leur
faire une place
alors oui ces minorités actives nous
interpelle tout comme j'ai été interpelé
la première fois par la présence de ce
salon
elle nous choque parfois nous pouvons
même avoir le sentiment qu'elles sont
une faiblesse de notre société
une faiblesse qu'il faudrait corriger
masquer un talon d'achille en somme
alors que faire place nette coup de
balai mais ce serait oublier que c'est
de ces minorités actives que naît
l'innovation sociale et culturelle et
qu'il n'existe pas d'innovation sociale
sans contestation sans transgression son
rapport de force sans volonté de
négociation alors au fil de cette
histoire j'ai reconsidéré mon regard sur
ce talon et j'y vois maintenant un objet
un objet grâce auquel des individus se
tiennent debout digne déterminé prêt à
lutter s'il le faut pour leurs droits
et tant qu'il le faudra alors vous
donneriez combien pour ça merci